thank you ladies and gentlemen I
Jacqueline wing Collins acting returning
officer for the rather and constituency
declare that the number of votes given
to each candidate was as follows Sarah
Debra champion Labour Party nineteen
thousand eight hundred and sixty votes
Jane Maria Collins UK Independence Party
eleven thousand four hundred and
fourteen votes sebastian michael lowe
Conservative Party 4656 votes Patrick
Antony mcglaughlin trade unionist and
socialist coalition 409 votes Janice
Middleton Liberal Democrats 1093 votes
Adam Walker British national party 225
votes dean walker English Democrats 166
votes there were 153 rejected papers I
bet therefore declare that Sarah Deborah
champion is duly elected as a member of
parliament for the rather and
constituents
and I am unbelievably honored and
humbled that the people of Rotherham
have put their faith back in me again
and it is with my greatest pleasure that
I will serve them for another five years
and I would do my absolute best to make
that happen there have been parties that
have been trying to divide this town and
have been making capital out of those
divisions and I am so proud that rather
and I said absolutely no way we are one
community we will stand together and we
will get the pride back into this town
together I will fight for a better deal
for other room I will fight for justice
for the victims and survivors of child
sexual abuse both in Rotherham but also
nationally I want to say that we will
work together to get more investment in
this town more employment in this town
and raise the expectation of our young
people and are now young people I want
to say thank you so much the number of
young voters that have got in touch and
said that they have voted for the very
first time and they voted for me they
voted for labor and also the number of
disaffected voters who've never voted in
their life who have come to labour and
come to support me I thank you hugely
for the faith that you've put in me and
put in the labour party I would also
like to thank the unbelievable
volunteers who have come out day after
day month after month to try and get a
fair a deal for this town and to try and
get a Labour government and I would also
like to thank the Labour team that have
stood behind me finally I want to say a
huge thanks to mags Evans Evers who has
been the Electoral Officer she has
managed this today and tonight so well
and thank you so so so much for all the
people that have been here until this
hour just to make sure that democracy is
served in this town I thank you all very
much